This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Many years ago, when Gloria Mark was visiting family in Austria, she found it difficult to get a reliable internet connection. My mother-in-law, who lived in a very small Austrian town, she didn't have Wi-Fi and I couldn't stay away from internet that long. And so what I did one day was walk around the neighborhood with my laptop open, looking at the bars on my computer to see when I might find a hotspot.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。许多年前，当格洛丽亚·马克在奥地利探亲时，她发现很难获得可靠的网络连接。我婆婆住在一个非常小的奥地利小镇上，她家没有Wi-Fi，而我又无法离开互联网那么久。因此，有一天我做的事就是拿着打开的笔记本电脑在社区里走来走去，看着电脑上的信号格，看看什么时候能找到一个热点。
And sure enough, I did find one. And I sat down on the edge of the front lawn of the house. And I was doing my email. In a little while, Gloria looked up to see she had company. Two elderly gentlemen came out of the house, they brought lawn chairs, and they sat down right in front of me. And they didn't say a word, and I didn't say anything to them. And I just wanted to get through my email.
果不其然，我真的找到一个。于是我在房子前草坪的边缘坐了下来。我正在处理邮件。过了一会儿，格洛丽亚抬头发现自己有伴了。两位老先生从房子里出来，他们搬来了草坪椅，直接坐在我面前。他们一句话也没说，我也没有对他们说任何话。我只想把邮件看完。
That was my goal. And I was certain they were going to ask me to leave it. And they did not look very friendly. So I didn't think it was going to be a friendly ask. And they just kept watching me. Gloria tried to think of a way to explain herself across the language barrier. After a while, I pointed to myself,
那就是我的目标。而且我确信他们会要求我离开。他们看起来并不怎么友好。所以我认为这不会是一个友善的要求。他们只是盯着我看。格洛丽亚试图想办法在语言不通的情况下解释自己。过了一会儿，我指了指自己，
and I said, California. And all of a sudden, they started laughing. And they said, Schwartzeneger, because at the time their Austrian son, actor turned governor, Arnold Schwartzeneger was the governor of California. And then I knew I had their approval and I could continue sitting there and I was able to finish my email. and I could continue sitting there and I was able to finish my email.
然后我说，加利福尼亚。突然间，他们大笑起来。他们说，施瓦辛格，因为当时他们的奥地利同胞、演员转行做州长的阿诺德·施瓦辛格正是加州州长。然后我知道我得到了他们的认可，我可以继续坐在那里，我也能够把邮件写完。然后我知道我得到了他们的认可，我可以继续坐在那里，我也能够把邮件写完。
Those were innocent times. In a few years, Gloria was to discover the opposite problem. The internet wasn't difficult to access. It was difficult to escape. With the advent of smartphones, we now get our email, news feeds and social media 24 hours a day, 7 days a week. It can be difficult nowadays to have a conversation with someone, without being constantly interrupted by text messages, email alerts and other notifications. This week on Hidden Brain, we examine the effects of being constantly online on our minds, our growing tendency to be distracted, and ways to recapture our focus and attention.
那是个纯真的年代。几年后，格洛丽亚发现了相反的问题。互联网不再难以接入。而是难以摆脱。随着智能手机的出现，我们现在每周7天、每天24小时都能收到电子邮件、新闻动态和社交媒体。如今，人们在交谈时很难不被短信、电子邮件提醒和其他通知不断打断。本周的《隐藏的大脑》中，我们将探讨持续在线对我们大脑的影响、我们日益严重的被分心倾向，以及重新夺回注意力和专注力的方法。
Whether it's the laptop on our desks, the cell phones in our hands, or the smartwatches on our wrists, we spend a lot of our lives looking at screens. Technology has made it possible for us to do remarkable things. We can stay in touch with friends and family who are hundreds of miles away and collaborate with colleagues who live in other states and countries. But what are the effects of all the screen time on our minds? At the University of California, Irvine, psychologist Gloria Mark studies how our capacity for focus is changing
无论是我们桌上的笔记本电脑、手里的手机，还是手腕上的智能手表，我们生命中的很大一部分时间都在盯着屏幕看。科技让我们能够做一些了不起的事情。我们可以与远在数百英里之外的朋友和家人保持联系，并与生活在其他州和国家的同事合作。但是，所有的屏幕时间对我们的大脑有什么影响呢？在加州大学欧文分校，心理学家格洛丽亚·马克研究了我们的专注力如何发生变化，
and how we can achieve greater harmony as we deal with many competing demands on our attention. Gloria Mark, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. Gloria, at the start of your career, you spent time working in Germany. I understand that lunch was an important part of your work day. What happened at lunchtime?
以及我们在应对许多相互冲突的注意力需求时，如何能够实现更大的和谐。格洛丽亚·马克，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我。格洛丽亚，在你的职业生涯初期，你曾在德国工作过一段时间。据我了解，午餐是你工作日的重要组成部分。午餐时间发生了什么？
That's right. In Germany, the main meal of the day occurs at lunchtime. It's called Mitagessen. The typical practice was for one colleague to walk around close to noon, gather up people, and then we would all go as a group to lunch. We would have our nice nice long, warm meal. We would have conversations, sometimes we would gossip. And even though we might have been talking about things very
没错。在德国，一天中最重要的一餐是在午餐时间。它被称为Mitagessen。通常的做法是，一名同事在接近中午时四处走动，把大家召集起来，然后我们就会成群结队地去吃午餐。我们会享用美味、漫长而温暖的一餐。我们会聊天，有时我们会八卦。尽管我们谈论的内容可能非常
different than our project at hand, I would say these conversations got the wheels of our minds churning and boosted our creativity. Plus, it helped us bond with our colleagues. Gloria left Germany in 2000 to join the faculty at the University of California Irvine. One of the first things she noticed in her new job was the difference at lunchtime. So, you know, when I came back to the US, you know, I had a heavy teaching load as an assistant professor, and I had meetings, and I had, you know, a lot of different work. Lunch was pretty much a break between classes
不同于我们手头上的项目，但我可以说，这些谈话让我们的思维运转起来，并提升了我们的创造力。此外，它有助于我们与同事建立联系。格洛丽亚于2000年离开德国，加入加州大学欧文分校的教职队伍。她在新工作中最先注意到的事情之一就是午餐时间的差异。所以，你知道的，当我回到美国时，你知道的，作为一名助理教授，我有繁重的教学任务，我有会议，而且我还有，你知道的，很多不同的工作。午餐基本上只是课程之间的休息时间，
to run to the cafeteria, grab, take away food, and then I would raise back to my office, would go down a long hallway, and all my colleagues had their doors open, and as I was racing down the hallway, I would look in at their different offices, see them sitting in front of their computers, eating their sandwiches,
跑去食堂，抓一份外卖食品，然后我会飞奔回办公室，走过一条长长的走廊，我所有的同事都敞开着办公室的门，当我飞奔过走廊时，我会看一眼他们不同的办公室，看到他们坐在电脑前吃三明治，
and then I would slide into my office in front of their computers, eating their sandwiches, and then I would slide into my office in front of my computer and do exactly the same thing. It wasn't just about lunch. Gloria found herself constantly sprinting from one thing to the next. There were so many things that changed when I came back to the U.S. I had classes I had to teach. I had multiple research projects, had to write grants, sit on committees, meet with students. I had to do service work. There were so many different things and I just found my attention to stay focused on any one thing. You once found yourself double-bucked
然后我会溜进我的办公室，坐在电脑前吃着三明治，接着我会溜进我的办公室，坐在电脑前做着完全相同的事情。这不仅仅是关于午餐。格洛丽亚发现自己一直在从一件事冲刺到另一件事。当我回到美国时，有太多事情变了。我有必须教授的课程。我有多个研究项目，必须写基金申请、参加委员会、与学生会面。我必须做行政服务工作。有太多不同的事情，我发现我的注意力很难专注于任何一件事情。你曾经发现自己被安排在同一时间
at two teleconferences at the same time. Tell me the story of what happened. Both of them were very important and I was too embarrassed to cancel either one of those conferences. So what I did is I sat there and I happened to be in a restaurant because I remember there was a lot of background noise and I had one earbud for one conference plugged into my computer
参加两个电话会议。跟我讲讲当时发生了什么。这两个会议都非常重要，而且我太不好意思取消其中任何一个了。所以我做的是坐在那里，我记得当时我是在一家餐厅里，因为我记得有很多背景噪音，我把一个会议的耳机插到我的电脑上，
and into my right ear and then the other earbud was plugged into my phone and then into my left ear. And I was trying to pay attention to both of these conferences and every so often my name would be called and every time I would hear my name call there there's something called the cocktail party phenomenon that if you hear your name all of a sudden you attend to it. So I was being asked to respond to something. And of course I couldn't hear what they were asking and especially with the background noise in the restaurant made it really difficult.
然后插进我的右耳，另一个会议的耳机插到我的手机上，然后插进我的左耳。我试图把注意力集中在这两个会议上，每隔一段时间就会有人叫我的名字，每当我听到有人叫我的名字时，有一种叫做鸡尾酒会效应的现象，如果你突然听到你的名字，你就会关注它。所以我被要求对某些事情做出回应。当然，我听不清他们在问什么，特别是餐厅里的背景噪音让事情变得非常困难。
And so I would cringe and I have to ask them to repeat the question. would cringe and have to ask them to repeat the question. And then I would put the other earbud back in my ear and go back to trying to shift my attention back and forth to each of these conferences. And of course my performance was terrible. I didn't do well in either one of these conferences. of these conferences. There was another time you were at a conference and a colleague of yours had his computer networked to the main display. And it gave you and everyone else a window into how many of us interact with our devices. Paint me a picture of what happened, Gloria.
所以我会有所畏惧，不得不请他们重复这个问题。我会畏缩，不得不要求他们重复这个问题。然后我把另一个耳机塞回耳朵里，继续尝试在这些会议之间来回切换我的注意力。当然，我的表现糟糕透顶。这两个会议我都没开好。还有一次你正在开会，你的一位同事把他的电脑连接到了主显示器上。这让你和其他所有人都有了一个窗口，得以一窥我们大多数人是如何与我们的设备互动的。格洛丽亚，给我描绘一下当时的情景。
Yeah, so this was what's called a program committee meeting. And this is where a group of people come together, discuss papers that have been reviewed, and the committee makes a decision as to which papers should be accepted and which ones not. So for everyone to keep track of the list of papers, one person's computer is networked to a large public display. So everyone can see this list of papers as we go through them.
好的，所以这是一个所谓的程序委员会会议。这是一个由一群人聚在一起，讨论已经过审的论文，并由委员会决定哪些论文应该被接受，哪些不应该被接受的会议。为了让每个人都能跟踪论文列表，一个人的电脑被连接到一个大型公共显示器上。这样在我们浏览时，每个人都可以看到这个论文列表。
This person whose computer was plugged into the display kept checking his email. So he kept changing the display, checking his email. So he kept, you know, changing the display, check his email. My guess is that it was so habitual for him to check his email that he probably just forgot that his computer was on public view for everyone to see. So in 2009, you got what you say was a wake-up call. What happened? What was this wake-up call? I received a diagnosis of stage three colon cancer. And it was shocking because I thought I was the healthiest person I knew.
这个电脑插在显示器上的人一直在查收邮件。所以他一直在切换显示屏，查收电子邮件。所以他一直，你知道的，在切换显示屏，检查邮件。我猜检查邮件对他来说已经成了习惯，他可能只是忘了他的电脑正在公开展出，供所有人观看。所以在2009年，你遇到了你所说的一个警钟。发生了什么？这个警钟是什么？我被诊断出患有三期结肠癌。这太令人震惊了，因为我以为自己是我认识的最健康的人。
I jogged, I ate healthy, I kept my weight down. But suddenly, I was told that I had a 69% five-year survival rate. This was shocking. But I was very determined to be in that 69% group. And I'm very happy to say that I was in that group and it have been cancer-free since. But the cause of the cancer was not known as many causes of cancer are just not known. They couldn't find anything genetic to explain it.
我慢跑，饮食健康，保持体重。但突然间，有人告诉我的五年生存率只有69%。这太令人震惊了。但我非常决心要成为那69%的人群之一。我很高兴地说我确实属于那个群体，并且从那以后一直没有癌症。但癌症的原因尚不清楚，就像许多癌症原因根本不清楚一样。他们找不到任何遗传解释来解释它。
But I can say that the years leading up to that diagnosis, I was undergoing just a tremendous amount of stress. And I remember at the time, I kept thinking, I'm going to pay the price for all this stress. Now, I can't attribute my cancer diagnosis directly to stress, and I can't attribute it directly to screen time. But I can say attribute it directly to screen time. But I can say that this cancer diagnosis was a wake-up call for me. And it made me realize that time is finite.
但我可以说，在确诊前的几年里，我正承受着巨大的压力。我记得当时我一直在想，我要为这所有的压力付出代价。现在，我不能把我的癌症诊断直接归咎于压力，也不能直接归咎于屏幕时间。但我可以把它直接归咎于屏幕时间。但我可以，这次癌症诊断对我来说是一个警钟。它让我意识到时间是有限的。
And being stressed is just not a good way for us to be spending our time, living our life. And so this health scare just made me very deeply aware that we need to rethink how we use our devices and how we need to really control our stress so that we can really focus on health and well-being. That's the most important thing. We can really focus on health and well-being. That's the most important thing. When we come back, why paying sustained attention is so valuable and so difficult.
而且处于压力之中绝对不是我们度过时间、生活的好方法。因此，这场健康危机让我深刻地意识到，我们需要重新思考我们如何使用设备，以及如何真正控制压力，以便我们真正专注于健康和幸福。这是最重要的事情。我们可以真正专注于健康和幸福。这是最重要的事情。当我们回来时，为什么保持持续的注意力如此宝贵又如此困难。
You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Gloria Mark is a psychologist at the University of California Irvine. She studies how we pay attention and when we get distracted. Gloria, you once heard an unusual story from your doctor about his desperate efforts to battle the distractions of the internet. What did he tell you? My doctor knew about my research. And so he volunteered to me that when he had to write a grant, he would book himself a round trip ticket from California to Washington, D.C.
你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。格洛丽亚·马克是加州大学欧文分校的心理学家。她研究我们如何集中注意力以及我们何时分心。格洛丽亚，你曾经听你的医生讲过一个不寻常的故事，关于他拼命努力与互联网的分心作斗争的故事。他跟你说了什么？我的医生了解我的研究。所以他主动告诉我，当他需要写基金申请时，他会给自己订一张从加州到华盛顿特区的往返机票。
Now why did he do this? And he said, because on an airplane, you don't have Wi-Fi. At least you can. You have the opportunity to not have Wi-Fi. And I said to him, but on an airplane, there are so many other kinds of distractions. People are talking and walking by,
他为什么要这么做？他说，因为在飞机上，你没有Wi-Fi。至少你可以。你有机会不用Wi-Fi。我对他说，但是在飞机上，还有很多其他各种分心的事情。人们在说话，在旁边走来走去，
and babies are crying. And he said, no, no, those don't distract me. It's the internet. And I said, isn't it easier to just stay at home and turn off the internet? And he said, he can't. He actually had to physically change his environment to prevent himself from getting on the internet. Was the doctor who told you the story and aberration? Did you have heard similar things from other people, Gloria? Yes, and so every so often, I'll get emails from people who tell me about the difficulties they have with distractions.
还有婴儿在哭闹。他说，不，不，那些不会让我分心。是互联网。我说，待在家里并关掉互联网不是更容易吗？他说，他做不到。他实际上必须改变他的物理环境，以防止自己上网。给你讲这个故事的医生是个特例吗？你有没有从其他人那里听到过类似的事情，格洛丽亚？是的，所以每隔一段时间，我就会收到人们发来的电子邮件，向我讲述他们分心的困难。
One email in particular really struck me as very characteristic. This person wrote, trying to articulate the difficulty with workplace distractions is like chasing a greased pig. I feel like every day my work is to definitely navigate the complexities of this job with the accuracy
其中有一封电子邮件尤其让我印象深刻，觉得非常具有代表性。这个人写道，试图阐明工作场所分心的困难就像是在抓一只抹了油的猪。我觉得我每天的工作就是在应对这项工作的复杂性时，保持准确性，
while being bombarded with emails, personal appearances by fellow coworkers, phone calls and texts. I leave work drained, not physically but mentally. I detest these devices that I think we are all slaves to. To get a grasp on the extent of the problem of workplace distractions, Gloria and her colleagues began to track people as they sat before their computers at work. I'm trained in psychology, and typically what psychologists do is they bring people into a laboratory, and they will create an artificial model of the world
同时还要受到电子邮件、同事的亲自造访、电话和短信的狂轰滥炸。我下班时精疲力竭，不是体力上的，而是精神上的。我痛恨这些设备，我觉得我们都是它们的奴隶。为了掌握工作场所分心问题的严重程度，格洛丽亚和她的同事开始追踪人们坐在电脑前工作时的状态。我是学心理学出身的，心理学家通常的做法是将人们带入实验室，并创造一个世界的为人造模型，
so that you can focus on a particular variable to measure. But, you know, our use of devices, our computers, our phones, it's so embedded in our lives that it's really hard to separate the rest of people's lives from their use of their devices. So I thought it was more important to go where people are. And so I created what I call living laboratories so that I could study people's use of their devices in their natural environments. And to do this, we originally started out shadowing people with stopwatches.
以便你可以专注于一个特定的变量来测量。但是，你知道，我们对设备的使用、我们的电脑、我们的手机，已经深深融入了我们的生活中，以至于很难将人们生活的其余部分与他们对设备的使用分离开来。所以我认为去人们所在的地方更重要。因此，我创造了我所谓的活体实验室，以便我可以在自然环境中研究人们对设备的使用。为了做到这一点，我们最初是通过用秒表跟踪人们来开始的。
So every time people switched their screen, we would click stop time, note the time, start time for the new screen or the new activity. And then around 2011, we started using software logging. So we could look at people's screens switching unobtrusively and automatically without having someone behind them, shadowing them. And we also would have people wear heart rate monitors, which gives a measure of what's called heart rate variability, which is a measure of stress. We would also have people answer very short question, which gives their subjective perception about what they're experiencing. And what you do is you put all of these different measures together in time, so that at any point in time, you have a pretty comprehensive idea of what people
因此，每次人们切换屏幕时，我们会点击停止时间，记录时间，然后记录新屏幕或新活动的开始时间。然后在大约2011年，我们开始使用软件日志记录。这样我们就可以在不引人注目且自动的情况下观察人们的屏幕切换，而不需要有人在他们身后跟踪他们。我们还会让人们佩戴心率监测器，这可以测量所谓的“心率变异性”，这是衡量压力的一个指标。我们还会让人们回答非常简短的问题，这能反映他们对所经历事情的主观感受。你要做的是将所有这些不同的测量结果按时间组合在一起，以便在任何时间点上，你都能对人们在使用设备时的感受有一个相当全面的了解。
are experiencing as they're using their devices. I'm wondering what you've observed in your many hours of observation as you watch people at work. What do you pick up, Gloria? So one of the things we've observed, and I've been doing this for about 20 years, is that the amount of attention duration on any one screen has decreased over time. So when we first started studying this back in 2004, we found that people's average attention on any screen was about two and a half minutes. And then in 2012, this went down to about 75 seconds on average. And then from about 2016 through 2020, this was like right before the pandemic started, we found the average attention to be 47 seconds.
我想知道在你数小时的观察中，当你看着人们工作时，你观察到了什么。你发现了什么，格洛丽亚？所以我们观察到的其中一件事——我已经做这个研究大约20年了——是在任何一个屏幕上的注意力持续时间随着时间的推移而减少了。因此，当我们最初在2004年开始研究时，我们发现人们在任何屏幕上的平均注意力大约是两分半钟。然后到2012年，这个数字平均下降到大约75秒。然后从2016年左右到2020年，也就是大流行开始前不久，我们发现平均注意力是47秒。
So it was diminishing over time. It was diminishing over time and others have replicated it. So people found 44 seconds, 50 seconds, we found 47 seconds, but the average of all these studies comes to 47 seconds on average. Are you taking into account that people might be on the same screen but switching between apps? So, in other words, they're on one screen, but they're in fact doing many different things on that one screen. That's exactly what we are measuring.
所以它在随着时间推移而减少。它在随着时间推移而减少，其他人也复制了这一发现。因此，人们发现是44秒、50秒，我们发现是47秒，但所有这些研究的平均值平均为47秒。你是否考虑到人们可能在同一个屏幕上，但在不同的应用程序之间切换？换句话说，他们在一个屏幕上，但实际上在那个屏幕上做很多不同的事情。这正是我们正在测量的。
So, the idea is that whatever window is in the foreground is what people are paying attention to. So, even though a person is just on one computer screen, if you're clicking on email, it's the email application that appears on your screen. If you click to work on a Word document, it's the Word document that appears on your screen. If you click to social media, it's the social media.
所以，这个想法是，无论哪个窗口在最前端，就是人们正在关注的窗口。因此，即使一个人只是在一个电脑屏幕上，如果你点击电子邮件，出现在你屏幕上的是电子邮件应用程序。如果你点击处理Word文档，出现在你屏幕上的是Word文档。如果你点击社交媒体，那就是社交媒体。
So that's what we're measuring is the amount of time that people are spending on these different screens, as the screens are switching. There are other intersecting lines of evidence that suggest our capacity for sustained attention is diminishing. One interesting piece of evidence comes from another type of screen that we watch incessantly. Our TV screens.
所以我们测量的是人们在屏幕切换时在这些不同屏幕上花费的时间。还有其他相互交叉的证据表明，我们持续专注的能力正在减弱。一个有趣的证据来自我们不间断观看的另一种屏幕。我们的电视屏幕。
Yeah, when TV and film first started out, shot lengths were much longer than they are now. And shot lengths have also decreased over time, and they now average about four seconds. Now, a way to see this very clearly is to look at your TV and turn the volume completely down. And then you really notice the fast shot changes. If you watch a blockbuster film like the Transformers, shot lengths change about every two seconds or so. So film editors and directors design these fast shot lengths to keep us engaged in these films. The idea is that if they're changing rapidly,
是的，当电视和电影刚开始时，镜头长度比现在要长得多。镜头长度也随着时间的推移而缩短，现在平均大约为四秒钟。现在，要非常清楚地看到这一点，可以看一下电视并把音量完全调小。然后你就会真正注意到快速的镜头变化。如果你看像《变形金刚》这样的大片，镜头大约每两秒钟就会改变一次。因此，电影剪辑师和导演设计这些快速的镜头长度，是为了让我们保持对这些电影的投入。这个想法是，如果它们在迅速变化，
these films. The idea is that if they're changing rapidly, we're not going to get bored. And I'm wondering if the relationship here is bidirectional with what's happening inside our minds. In other words, we actually have shorter attention spans, and so the movies and television shows are catering to that. But the fact that movies and television shows now have so many shot changes also changes how our minds are working. I do think it's bidirectional. We can't say what is causing what, and it could also be that film editors and film directors are influenced by their own short attention spans. And so they're designing these short shot lengths based on what they perceive to be interesting. In the workplace, Gloria finds that instead of focusing on one thing at a time, people rapidly cycle
这些电影。这个想法是，如果它们快速变化，我们就不会觉得无聊。我想知道这里的关系是否与我们脑海中发生的事情双向相关。换句话说，我们的注意力持续时间实际上变短了，所以电影和电视节目正在迎合这一点。但电影和电视节目现在有这么多镜头变化这一事实，也改变了我们大脑的工作方式。我确实认为这是双向的。我们无法说是什么导致了什么，也有可能是电影剪辑师和导演受到了他们自己短注意力跨度的影响。因此，他们根据自己认为有趣的东西来设计这些短镜头。在工作场所，格洛丽亚发现，人们不是一次专注于一件事，而是迅速在活动之间循环，
between activities. But much of this activity has a circular feel to it. Like restless animals pacing in a cage, many of us return incessantly to the same apps over and over has a circular feel to it. Like restless animals pacing in a cage, many of us return incessantly to the same apps over and over with not much to show for it. We found that people checked email on average 77 times a day.
但其中大部分活动都有一种循环的感觉。就像笼子里焦躁不安的动物在踱步一样，我们中的许多人不断地回到相同的应用程序，而没有什么实质性的成果。我们发现人们平均每天检查电子邮件77次。
These were information workers. We measured them during the work day. The previous study we had done a couple of years earlier, we found 74 times a day on average. And that's on average, which means that some people might be even more than 77 times a day. Yes, one person on our sample checked over 400 times a day. My God. So you know, when I'm working, I often tell myself, you know, I'm working on something, but then I say, I'll attend to some other thing for just a second. I tell myself, it'll only be a second.
这些是信息工作者。我们在工作日对他们进行了测量。我们几年前做的前一项研究发现平均每天74次。这还是平均值，这意味着有些人每天检查的次数甚至可能超过77次。是的，我们样本中的一个人一天检查了400多次。天哪。所以你知道的，当我工作时，我经常告诉自己，你知道的，我正在做一件事，但随后我说，我会花一秒钟处理其他事情。我告诉自己，只需要一秒钟。
But then as I'm attending to the new thing, something else pops up, and I tell myself, I look at that for just a second. You know, now I'm on task number three. Can you talk about the idea of nested interruptions and how long it takes people to return to their original tasks? Yes, that's a really interesting thing that we noticed. Is that, you know, people generally think you're interrupted and then you go right back to the task that you were interrupted from. But that's not the typical pattern of behavior. The typical pattern is that a person is interrupted
但是，当我关注新事物时，又会有别的事情跳出来，我告诉自己，我看一眼那个只需一秒钟。你知道的，现在我正在处理任务三。你能谈谈嵌套中断的概念以及人们需要多长时间才能返回原始任务吗？是的，这是我们注意到一个非常有趣的事情。那就是，人们通常认为你被打断了，然后你就会直接回到打断你的那个任务中。但这并不是典型的行为模式。典型的模式是一个人被打断了，
and then they're interrupted from that interruption and then they're interrupted again. And then they go back to the original task. That's the general pattern of behavior. We find that people average about 10 and a half minutes working in a project before they're interrupted and moved to something else. Keep in mind, within each project, there's lots of switching. So the difficulty is that when you're interrupted, it's not just a single interruption, but you're continually being interrupted
然后他们被那个中断所打断，接着又被打断。然后他们才回到原来的任务。这就是普遍的行为模式。我们发现人们在一个项目上平均工作大约10分半钟，然后就会被打断并转向其他事情。请记住，在每个项目内，有很多切换。所以困难在于，当你被打断时，它不仅仅是一个单一的中断，而是你不断地被打断，
again and again. And so it's really hard to go back and reorient to the original task. Does the data tell us how long it takes us on average to get back to task number one? It takes on average about 25 and a half minutes. Wow. So those interruptions are not just, I'll check something for one second. It never is a second. It's never a second. Remember, we're talking about looking at the level of a project. You're working a project interrupted from that,
一次又一次。所以很难回去并重新适应原来的任务。数据有没有告诉我们，我们平均需要多长时间才能回到任务一？平均大约需要25分半钟。哇。所以这些中断不仅仅是，我查看某事一秒钟。从来都不是一秒钟。从来都不是一秒钟。请记住，我们谈论的是在项目层面上看。你在一个项目上工作，从中被打断，
moving to another project, and to another project, starting to work on another project, and then going back. So, many of us complain about getting distracted by others, by bosses, by friends, by co-workers, but you found that we have become so conditioned to expect frequent distractions that if the outside world doesn't interrupt us, we just interrupt ourselves. This was one of the most surprising things that we found in our research. Going back to when we were shadowing people and observing them, for no apparent reason, someone would suddenly stop in the middle of, say, working on a word document, and then
转向另一个项目，再转向另一个项目，开始在一个项目上工作，然后再回去。所以，我们许多人抱怨被其他人、老板、朋友、同事打断，但你发现我们已经变得如此习惯于期待频繁的分心，以至于如果外界不打断我们，我们就会自己打断自己。这是我们在研究中发现的最令人惊讶的事情之一。回到我们跟踪和观察人们的时候，出于某种明显的原因，有人会在比如处理Word文档的中途突然停下来，然后
they would check email, or they would pick up their phone. And there was no external stimulus that was triggering them to make that switch. There was something inside themselves. And I've thought about this quite a bit, and I realize for myself how often I self-interrupt. And I might have an urge to do something and we've asked people why do you self-interrupt? Well, because people have memories of something they forgot to do or they're cute to some information in the current task to do something else. So there's lots of reasons or because they're bored and then they're attention wanders.
他们会查看电子邮件，或者拿起手机。没有任何外部刺激触发他们进行这种切换。他们内心有什么东西。我对此思考了相当多，并且意识到自己经常自我打断。我可能有一种冲动想去做某事，我们曾问过人们为什么会自我打断？好吧，因为人们记起了他们忘记做的事情，或者他们被当前任务中的某些信息提示去做别的事情。所以有很多原因，或者因为他们感到无聊，然后他们的注意力就开始游离。
What I'm almost hearing Gloria is that we have something of an internal clock in our heads and after we've worked on something for a little while, we are so used to getting interrupted, so used to switching between tasks, that that little clock goes off and the alarm goes off and we say, okay, I've been working at this thing for five minutes, surely I must have to do something else right now. Since there's nothing else that's actually interrupting us, we go ahead and do it ourselves. So, what we found in our data was we looked at the number of interruptions that come from some external trigger, like a notification or a phone call. And then we also looked at the number of interruptions that come from within a person,
我听到的格洛丽亚的感觉是，我们的大脑里有一个内部时钟，在我们工作了一小段时间之后，我们太习惯于被打断了，太习惯于在任务之间切换了，以至于那个小闹钟响了，警报响了，我们说，好吧，我已经在这件事上工作了五分钟，现在我肯定得做点别的了。既然没有其他事情真正在打断我们，我们就继续自己做。所以，我们在数据中发现的是，我们查看了来自某个外部触发因素的中断次数，例如通知或电话。然后我们还查看了来自个人内部的中断次数，
right? People self-interrupt. And we find that when the number of external interruptions goes down interruptions goes down in the next hour. The number of self-interruptions goes up. So it's almost as if people want to maintain this level of interruptions. And if you're not being interrupted by something external to yourself, then you self-interrupt. Can you remember a time when you interrupted yourself, Gloria? Oh, I interrupt myself all the time. It's very common. So I was reading an article about AI and for some reason, the thought popped into my head. How safe is it to eat non-organic strawberries. It's just a completely random thought. And I simply had to look it up. Of course. So I self-interrupted when on the internet and looked up to see whether it was safe or not. So you read up on strawberries and pesticides and I'm guessing they were probably other rabbit holes
对吧？人们会自我打断。我们发现，当外部中断的次数减少时，在接下来的一个小时里，自我打断的次数会增加。所以这几乎就像人们想要保持这种水平的中断一样。如果你没有受到外部事物的干扰，那么你就会自我干扰。你还记得你自我打断的时候吗，格洛丽亚？哦，我一直在自我打断。这太常见了。所以我在读一篇关于人工智能的文章，出于某种原因，一个想法突然闯入我的脑海。吃非有机草莓有多安全？这完全是一个随机的想法。我不得不查一下。当然。所以我自我打断了，上了互联网，查了一下它是否安全。所以你研究了草莓和杀虫剂，我猜你从那里开始可能还陷入了其他兔子洞。
that you went down from there. Oh, for sure, because then of course I started thinking about other fruits and vegetables. Gloria says that a central driver of our increasing levels of distractedness is that the human brain, which has a finite capacity for attention, is finding itself in a losing battle with the avalanche of information and options on the internet and social media.
哦，当然，因为接着我当然开始考虑其他水果和蔬菜了。格洛丽亚说，我们分心程度不断上升的一个核心驱动因素是，人类大脑的注意力容量是有限的，却发现自己在与互联网和社交媒体上雪崩般的信息和选项的斗争中处于下风。
I mean, we live in an age where we have access to more information and more people than ever before in history, but ultimately, the mind is a bottleneck. The human mind can't process all that information. So when we have so many friends on, say, Facebook or other social media, it's just not possible to have any kind of meaningful relationship with so many people. And there's something called the Dunbar number, Robin Dunbar is a British psychologist. And he found that people realistically can have about five meaningful relationships. And they can have about 150 other relationships with which may not be very close or meaningful, but at least you can say that this is a friend. But you
我的意思是，我们生活在一个拥有比以往任何时候都多的信息和更多人的时代，但归根结底，大脑是一个瓶颈。人类的大脑无法处理所有这些信息。因此，当我们有那么多朋友在脸书或其他社交媒体上时，与这么多人建立任何有意义的关系简直是不可能的。有一个叫做邓巴数的概念，罗宾·邓巴是一位英国心理学家。他发现，人们实际上可以拥有大约五个有意义的关系。他们可以拥有大约150个其他关系，这些关系可能不是很亲密或有意义，但至少可以说这是一个朋友。但是你
know, on social media, because it scales up so high, it's just not possible to conceive of having meaningful relationships with so many people. Let's talk a moment about multitasking. We all know it can be difficult to do two things at once, but you also say that they can be hidden costs to switching between activities. You describe these costs using the metaphor of a whiteboard. Describe this metaphor for me, Gloria. So every time we switch our attention, going from one test to another, you can think of it as having a whiteboard in your mind, an internal whiteboard.
知道，在社交媒体上，因为它的规模太大了，所以根本无法想象与这么多人建立有意义的关系。让我们花一点时间来谈谈多任务处理。我们都知道同时做两件事可能很困难，但你也说过，在活动之间切换也会带来隐藏的成本。你用白板的隐喻来描述这些成本。请为我描述这个隐喻，格洛丽亚。所以每次我们转移注意力，从一个测试转移到另一个测试时，你可以把它想象成你的大脑中有一块白板，一块内部白板。
And so just like with a real whiteboard, when you write information on that whiteboard, and then you erase it, sometimes you can't erase it completely, and sometimes there's a residue. And the same thing happens with our minds. So let's say I'm reading the news and I read about some horrific story. That creates a residue. So even though I'm switching and I'm in a completely different task, the residue from that news article stays with me and it creates interference from my current task at hand. So it's very difficult when we do this attention switching. It's hard to make a clean break, right? There's generally
就像真正的白板一样，当你在那块白板上写下信息然后擦除它时，有时你无法完全擦除它，有时会有残留物。我们的头脑也会发生同样的事情。假设我在看新闻，我读到了一些可怕的故事。这会产生残留物。因此，即使我正在切换并且正在处理完全不同的任务，该新闻文章的残留物仍然留在我身边，并对我和手头上的任务产生干扰。所以当我们进行这种注意力切换时，这是非常困难的。很难做一个干净的断裂，对吧？通常会有
going to be some kind of interference from previous tasks. So Gloria, you've studied the effects of these distractions on our propensity to make errors, and specifically you've looked at the domain of healthcare. What do you find? So, first of all, let me say that there have been decades of studies in the laboratory that show that when people in multitask, they make more errors. There was a study done of physicians. The researchers shadowed physicians in their real work environments, and they noted down every time physicians were interrupted
某种来自先前任务的干扰。所以格洛丽亚，你研究了这些干扰对我们犯错倾向的影响，特别是你研究了医疗保健领域。你发现了什么？首先，我要说的是，实验室里进行了几十年的研究表明，当人们进行多任务处理时，他们会犯更多错误。有一项针对医生的研究。研究人员在真实的办公环境中跟踪医生，并记录下医生被打断和进行多任务处理的每一次时间。
and were multitasking. And as you can imagine, physicians are interrupted quite frequently by other people, by devices, by beepers. And it turns out that the more times that physicians multitasked and were interrupted, the more errors they made in prescriptions. And some of these errors were quite serious in terms of writing down wrong medications and wrong dosages. So when people's attention is diverted from what they're doing, it's very easy to make errors. We live in a world saturated with distractions. Imagining that we can cut ourselves off from these distractions can be appealing, but is often not realistic.
正如你所想象的那样，医生经常被其他人、设备、传呼机打断。事实证明，医生进行多任务处理和被打断的次数越多，他们在开处方时犯的错误就越多。其中一些错误在写错药物和错误剂量方面相当严重。因此，当人们的注意力从他们正在做的事情转移时，犯错误是非常容易的。我们生活在一个充满干扰的世界中。想象一下我们可以切断自己与这些干扰的联系可能很有吸引力，但往往并不现实。
We need to be able to respond to emergencies, work collaboratively with colleagues, and allow ourselves to learn from the inexhaustible knowledge that is available on the internet. When we come back, how to find focus in a world filled with distractions? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Gloria Mark studies the psychology of attention.
我们需要能够应对紧急情况，与同事协同工作，并让自己从互联网上取之不尽的知识中学习。当我们回来时，如何在充满干扰的世界中找到焦点？你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。格洛丽亚·马克研究注意力心理学。
She's the author of Attention Span, a groundbreaking way to restore balance, happiness, and productivity. She says the first step to fighting distraction is to notice it. I realize that when we use our devices so many of the things we do are unconscious. So I see my phone next to me and I have this automatic reaction to grab it and swipe it open. Or I might have an automatic reaction to click on a notification or to self-interrupt and turn to social media. And so I learned to ask myself, why do I have this urge to go to social media?
她是《注意力跨度：恢复平衡、幸福和生产力的开创性方法》一书的作者。她说，对抗分心的第一步是注意到它。我意识到，当我们使用设备时，我们做的很多事情都是无意识的。所以看到手机在我旁边，我就会产生一种自动反应，去抓它并滑动打开它。或者我可能会对点击通知或自我打断并转向社交媒体产生自动反应。所以我学会了问自己，我为什么会有这种去社交媒体的冲动？
Why do I have this urge to check my email right now? And so what this meta awareness does is that it's raising unconscious activities to a more conscious level. And when we can become more conscious of them, we can be more intentional and we can create plans. For example, if I have an urge to go to social media and I become aware that I'm about to switch, I can say, okay, Gloria, I'm going to work 20 more minutes and then I can reward myself with a break. I understand that you use this technique as you were writing your book.
我为什么现在有这种查看电子邮件的冲动？这种元意识所做的是，它将无意识的活动提升到更有意识的水平。当我们能够更加意识到它们时，我们可以更有意图并制定计划。例如，如果我有去社交媒体的冲动并且我意识到我即将切换，我可以告诉自己，好的，格洛丽亚，我再工作20分钟，然后我可以用休息来犒劳自己。我听说你在写书时使用了这个技巧。
Yes, I'm a news junkie and there was a trial of very well-known personality. And I knew that the results of the trial were going to be broadcast at any moment. And I did see a notification of my screen that announced that the trial results were going to be announced. And rather than click on it, which I knew would distract me for quite a long time, I probe myself and said, do I really need to look at that right now? And the answer is no. So I continued working. And then I was able to look at the results when I took a break.
是的，我是一个新闻迷，当时有一个非常知名人物的审判。我知道审判结果随时都会广播。我确实在屏幕上看到了一条通知，宣布审判结果即将公布。我没有点击它，我知道这会让我分心很长一段时间，我试探自己并问，我现在真的需要看那个吗？答案是不。所以我继续工作。然后我能够在休息时查看结果。
In other words, once you're actually sort of trying to, you're making the choice deliberately, in some ways the choice becomes easier to forego because you can say, do I actually want to make the choice? So much of this is happening because it's happening unthinkingly. That's right, yes. So you become more in control of your actions. A second way that you have recommended to push back against distractions is to practice something that you call forethought by imagining the state you'll be in in the very near future. Can you tell me how you use forethought to avoid getting
换句话说，一旦你实际上开始尝试，你就是在刻意做出选择，在某些方面，选择变得更容易放弃，因为你可以说，我真的想做出这个选择吗？这其中有很多发生是因为它是无意识地发生的。没错，是的。所以你可以更好地控制你的行动。你推荐的抵制分心的第二种方法是练习你所谓的“前瞻”，方法是想象你在不久的将来所处的État（状态）。你能告诉我你是如何使用前瞻来避免分心的吗？
distracted? So forethought is about imagining our future selves and how we want our future selves to be. And I think it makes the most sense to think of our future selves at the end of a work day. And so I ask myself, what do I want to do at the end of the day? How do I want to do at the end of the day? How do I want to feel? So I want to see myself relaxing, maybe watching my favorite show, being with family or friends. How do I want to feel? I want to feel rewarded and fulfilled.
前瞻就是想象我们未来的自己以及我们希望未来的自己成为什么样的人。我认为考虑我们工作日结束时的未来自己最有意义。所以我问自己，我想在一天结束时做什么？我希望在一天结束时感觉怎么样？所以我想看到自己放松，也许在看我最喜欢的节目，和家人或朋友在一起。我希望有什么感觉？我希望感到被回报和满足。
And the more concrete of a visualization, you can form about your future self at the end of the day, the more powerful it is to keep you in check and keep you on task. In other words, our goals are one way to hold off distractions. The clearer our goals are in our heads, the easier it becomes to say, I don't want to go to down this side alley because it's going to keep me from getting to my goal. Exactly. And it's about making your goals very concrete, creating a visualization of these goals. And don't forget, it's not just about thinking of finishing the task, but it's also about thinking how you will feel emotional. You'll feel relaxed, you'll feel relieved. I understand that you're a fan of
你在一天结束时对未来的自己形成的具象化可视化越清晰，它让你保持清醒和专注的力量就越强大。换句话说，我们的目标是抵御分心的一种方式。我们在头脑中的目标越清晰，就越容易说，我不想走这条小路，因为它会阻止我达到目标。完全正确。这不仅关乎让你的目标非常具体，还要为这些目标创建一个可视化。不要忘记，它不仅关乎思考完成任务，还关乎思考你的情绪感受。你会感到放松，你会感到宽慰。我听说你是
the online game PanGram. Tell me about this game Gloria and how it speaks to the the issue of distraction and destructibility. PanGram is a very easy and engaging game making anagrams, and you reach different levels. And it's a way to help relax my mind. Now, of course, I can get stuck in this game, and I don't want to be playing this for, you know, long periods of time. But it's okay to play it for a few minutes, especially if I just had, you know, a very difficult meeting or, you know, I just need to clear my head from having done a lot of work. It's okay to spend a few minutes doing something easy, mindless, broke to help relax yourself. But the key thing is that you have to make sure
在线游戏PanGram的粉丝。告诉我这个游戏，格洛丽亚，以及它如何说明分心和易受干扰的问题。PanGram是一个非常简单且引人入胜的字谜游戏，你可以达到不同的级别。这是帮助放松头脑的一种方式。当然，我可能会沉迷于这个游戏，我不想玩很长时间。但是玩几分钟是可以的，特别是如果我刚刚开了一个非常困难的会议，或者，你知道的，我只是需要理清做大量工作后的思绪。花几分钟做一些轻松、无脑、机械的事情来帮助自己放松是可以的。但关键是你必须确保
that it really is a short period of time. So you may want to set a timer or you may want to create what I call a hook, which is you do this broke activity five minutes before you have a meeting. And you know, you've got to be at that meeting and that's going to pull you out. Some people talk about doing knitting as a road activity. One person told me he has this ball that he throws on a screen in his office. And that's his road activity.
这段时间其实非常短暂。所以你可能想设个定时器，或者设立我所说的“钩子”——也就是在开会前五分钟做这种机械活动。你知道自己接下来必须去开会，这会把你拉回来。有些人把织毛衣当作机械活动。曾有人告诉我，他办公室里有一个球，他会把它朝屏幕扔去。这就是他的机械活动。
The great writer Maya Angelo talked about her big mind and her little mind, and her big mind was used for her deep thought, for doing her writing. And then every so often, she'd break away, and she'd use her little mind, which is when she would do crossword puzzles or other kinds of simple activities. and she did that to relax and clear her head. I love that story because what it says is that in fact we have these different needs in our minds and it's not a problem that we have a need for distraction or
伟大的作家玛雅·安杰洛曾谈到过她的“大心”和“小心”。她的“大心”用于深度思考和写作。然后每隔一段时间，她会抽离出来，使用她的“小心”，这时她会做填字游戏或其他简单的活动，她这样做是为了放松和清空大脑。我很喜欢这个故事，因为它表明，实际上我们大脑有这些不同的需求，我们需要分心并不是什么问题，或者说
a need for road activity. The problem arises when those activities carry us away and then we add down rabbit holes and we forget the needs of, you know, what Maya and Julie would call our big mind. Yes, there is nothing wrong with doing some simple mindless game like PanGram, as long as you put a limit on it. And as long as you know, you know, there's a purpose to it. The purpose is to help you relax, clear your head so that you can go back and do other
需要机械活动也不是问题。问题在于，当这些活动把我们带走，让我们陷入兔子洞，而我们却忘记了玛雅·安杰洛所说的“大心”的需求。是的，玩一些像拼词（PanGram）这样简单的无脑游戏并没有错，只要你为它设定限制。只要你知道，这样做是有目的的。其目的是为了帮你放松、清空大脑，这样你就能回去做其他
things that are really important to do. Another technique that you recommend is that people check their email only twice a day. Do you do this yourself? Not as often as I should, but it is something that when I do it, it's very valuable. I'm a fan of batching email. You know, you check your email first thing in the morning and then you check it mid-day, maybe after lunch, and then at the end of the day. So twice a day is good as well. One thing that I discovered is that email ages very
真正重要的事情。你推荐的另一个技巧是人们一天只查两次邮件。你自己也这样做吗？不如我应该做的那样频繁，但每当我这样做时，都觉得非常有价值。我是批量处理邮件的拥趸。你看，你早上第一件事就是查邮件，然后在中午——可能在午饭后——再查一次，最后在一天结束时再查一次。所以一天查两次也很好。我发现的一件事是，邮件“老化”得非常
fast. So you might get the most urgent email that sent you first thing in the morning. And if you don't deal with it until the end of the day, you might discover, oh, the problem has already been solved. Or the person writes back and said, ah, I got the information that I need. At the same time, Gloria, when you don't respond to a question that, let's say, a coworker is asking you, at least some of the time what happens is
快。所以你可能会收到一封别人一大早发给你的最紧急的邮件。如果你直到一天结束才处理它，你可能会发现，哦，问题已经解决了。或者对方回信说，啊，我已经得到我需要的信息了。与此同时，格洛丽亚，当你不对同事提出的问题做出回应时，至少在某些时候会发生的情况是
that someone else might end up responding to it. So I certainly get the appeal of not wanting to be distracted, but surely in collaborative work environments, our desire to not be distracted can mean we are implicitly asking others to pick up the slack. That's very true. Here's the thing, the burden is placed on the email recipient. The sender is the one who benefits, but it's always the recipient who has to do the extra work. And I completely agree with you that we all need to be good citizens and do our part, especially if we're doing collaborative work. How much of what you're recommending is sort of about individuals
可能会有其他人去回复。所以我当然理解人们不想被打扰的心理，但在协作式的工作环境中，我们不想被打扰的愿望，意味着我们其实在隐晦地要求别人来收拾烂摊子。这非常真实。问题在于，负担转移到了邮件接收者身上。发送者是受益者，但总是接收者必须做额外的工作。我完全同意你的看法，我们所有人都需要做一个好公民，尽到自己的责任，特别是在进行协作工作时。你所推荐的内容中，有多少是关于个人的
and how much of it is about the structures and organizations in which individuals are embedded? Because when you came back from Germany to the United States, you came back to a very different kind of job and someone could say, look, you had a job in Germany that allowed you to focus on one or two projects. You just have a different job right now. And yes, of course, you might wish that the new job had the same level of distractedness, which is very little distractedness as your earlier job, but this is just a different
又有多少是关于个人所处的结构和组织的？因为当你从德国回到美国时，你面对的是一种非常完全不同的工作，有人可能会说，看，你在德国的工作允许你专注于一两个项目。你现在只是换了一份不同的工作。当然，你可能会希望新工作能像以前的工作那样，保持极低的干扰度，但这就是一份不同的
job. That's right. It is a different job. I do think that organizations bear some responsibility for helping people focus. So some organizations institute a quiet time during the day, usually two or three hours during the day where no electronic communications are sent and people are off the hook from having to answer electronic communications. And what this does is it helps reset expectations because email has its own set of norms as does slack, as does texting, that when you get these, you have to respond fast.
工作。没错。这确实是一份不同的工作。我确实认为组织在帮助人们专注方面负有一定的责任。因此，一些组织在白天设立了“静默时间”，通常是白天的两三个小时，期间不发送任何电子通讯，员工也不承担回复电子通讯的责任。这样做有助于重置期望值，因为邮件有它自己的一套规范，Slack和短信也是如此——当你收到这些东西时，你必须迅速回复。
And so the burden cannot just be on the individual to pull out, but there really has to be a collective solution that I believe organizations need to be responsible for. One of the ideas that you have proposed Gloria is that we all have fluctuations in our capacity for attention during the day. Talk about the idea of these attention rhythms and how we can take advantage of them. When most people think of attention, they think of there being two states, you're focused or unfocused. And as I've been studying attention, it occurred to me that there's another variable in the mix that's really important.
因此，不能仅仅把摆脱干扰的负担压在个人身上，真正需要的是一种集体解决方案，我认为组织需要为此承担责任。格洛丽亚，你曾提出过这样一个观点，即我们在一天当中的注意力容量是会波动的。谈谈这种注意力节律的概念以及我们如何利用它们。当大多数人想到注意力时，他们会认为有两种状态：专注或不专注。随着我对注意力的研究，我发现还有一个同样非常重要的变量存在于其中。
And that is how much mental effort is involved when you're paying attention. So there's things we do that can be very challenging, like trying to read a difficult article. And there's things we do that are very easy, like playing solitaire or playing a pangram game. So we did a research study where we asked people questions throughout the day. And people had to simply respond how engaged were you and the thing you were just doing
那就是当你集中注意力时，涉及多少心理努力。所以有些事情非常具有挑战性，比如试图阅读一篇难懂的文章。还有些事情非常简单，比如玩纸牌或玩拼词游戏。因此，我们做了一项研究，在一天当中不断向人们提问。人们只需要简单地回答：你在刚才做的事情中投入了多少精力
and how challenged were you and the thing you were just doing and how challenged were you and the thing you were just doing and so people responded we had time stamps and we contract their responses over the course of the day. Turns out that when we look at the focused state of attention being challenged and engaged we see a peak rhythm which is around mid-morning for most people and again about mid afternoon for most people. There are individual differences of course, but we do see that there are these peaks and valleys, so to speak, of attention throughout the day. How do we take advantage of that?
你在刚才做的事情中感到了多大的挑战，我们在一天当中追踪了他们的回答并记录了时间戳。结果显示，当我们观察注意力处于“既有挑战又高度投入”的专注状态时，我们会发现一个波峰节律，对大多数人来说大约在上午中段，而另一个波峰大约在下午中段。当然存在个体差异，但我们确实看到注意力在一天当中存在这种所谓的波峰和低谷。我们该如何利用这一点呢？
So if we have a number of tasks during the day and we know that we have these rhythms of attention, how should we marry the levels of our attention with the tasks that we have to accomplish? Think about what your peak focus times are. And think about planning to do those tasks that require the hardest work, the most thought, the most creative thinking during those times when your attention is at its peak. And for the times when our attention isn't a valley, that's when I do what I call subordinate work.
因此，如果我们一天当中有很多任务，并且知道注意力有这种节律，我们应该如何将注意力水平与我们要完成的任务结合起来呢？想想你注意力最集中的时间是什么时候。并计划在那些注意力达到巅峰的时刻，去做那些需要最艰苦工作、最多思考和最多创造性思维的任务。至于注意力处于低谷的时刻，那就是我所说的去做“从属工作”的时候。
You know, work that doesn't involve a lot of thought, but you know, simple work that needs to get done. There is one final idea on how we can fight distractions, and it is counterintuitive. Gloria says we can increase our capacity for focus if we consciously take breaks from the things we are focusing on. There is a Japanese expression that's called Yohaku nobi, which means the beauty of empty space. And there's a very well-known Japanese garden in Kyoto,
你知道，那些不需要太多思考、但又必须完成的简单工作。关于如何对抗干扰，还有一个最终的建议，而且它违背直觉。格洛丽亚说，如果我们有意识地从正在专注的事情中抽身出来休息，我们实际上可以提高我们的专注能力。日语中有一个表达叫“余白の美”（Yohaku nobi），意思是空白之美的意思。京都有一座非常著名的日本庭院，
which has the most beautiful rocks that are very carefully positioned. And what is as important as the rocks themselves is the space around the rocks because that space creates a kind of dynamism that makes these rocks more beautiful. And we can use that as a metaphor to think about our work day. So, of course, we want to perform the best that we possibly can. But we also have to design empty space into our day to enable our work to shine.
里面有非常精心放置的最美的岩石。和岩石本身同样重要的是岩石周围的空间，因为这种空间创造了一种动态感，让这些岩石显得更加美丽。我们可以将其作为思考工作日的隐喻。所以，当然，我们希望尽最大可能表现出色。但我们也必须在一天当中设计出空白空间，让我们的工作大放异彩。
Because otherwise, we just get exhausted. And what can you do during this empty space? Take a walk, go out in nature, that's the best break of all. You can meditate, you can contemplate. There's many different ways to hope your mind refresh. I understand that you used to be a painter before you were an academic. And when you're a painter, of course, you have to pay attention not just to watch your putting down on the canvas,
因为否则，我们只会精疲力竭。在这片空白空间里你能做什么？散步，去大自然中，这是最好的休息方式。你可以冥想，可以沉思。有很多不同的方法可以帮助你的大脑恢复活力。我听说你在成为学者之前曾是一名画家。当你成为一名画家时，当然，你不仅要注意你画在画布上的内容，
but the parts of the canvas that you are not painting. That's how I came to think about this idea of empty space or in painting, it's called negative space, where you have to really pay attention to the space around the figure and give that importance to. So it's a holistic understanding of the painting and that's how we have to think about our work day in a holistic sense. It's not just the time we do our work, but it's also the time that we devote to replenishing ourselves.
还要注意画布上你没有画的部分。这就是我开始思考这种“空白空间”概念的方式，或者在绘画中，它被称为“负空间”，你必须真正关注图形周围的空间，并赋予其重要性。因此，这是一种对绘画的整体理解，这就是我们必须以整体意识来思考工作日的方式。它不仅是我们工作的时间，也是我们用来恢复精力的时间。
that we devote to replenishing ourselves. [♪ Music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, Gloria, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Oh, thank you so much for having me. If you have additional questions about distraction and focus that you would like to ask Gloria Mark, and if you're willing to share those questions with the Hidden Brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at ideasathydenbrain.org. Use the subject line distraction. That email address again is ideasathydenbrain.org. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury.
我们用来恢复精力的时间。[背景音乐演奏……]格洛丽亚，非常感谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。哦，非常感谢邀请我。如果你对分心和专注还有其他想问格洛丽亚·马克的额外问题，并且愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享这些问题，请在手机上录制语音备忘录，并通过电子邮件发送给我们：ideas@hiddenbrain.org。主题行请使用 distraction。再次重复邮箱地址是 ideas@hiddenbrain.org。《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·夸雷莱、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。
Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brains executive editor. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制作人。我是《隐藏的大脑》执行主编。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。再见。此剧集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。